now to Washington where House Democrats
are gearing up to hear testimony from
key witnesses this week in the
impeachment inquiry of President Trump a
new CBS News poll shows a majority of
Americans 53% approve of the inquiry 46
percent disapprove that's largely split
along party lines 63 percent in the poll
say the Trump administration should
cooperate with the inquiry Nancy Cordes
is on Capitol Hill Nancy the inquiry
continues what are we learning about
what some of these witnesses will say
good morning well today lawmakers are
going to be interviewing Fiona Hill she
is a Russia expert a former White House
official who is expected to say that
Trump loyalists went outside the usual
channels when dealing with Ukraine it
comes as vice president son's fight Vice
President Biden's son hunter announces
that he is going to be stepping down
from his position on the board of a
Chinese investment firm
no one has asserted that I have done
anything wrong except a lying president
speaking to reporters in Iowa former
Vice President Biden praised his son's
decision announced Sunday not to serve
on boards of or work on behalf of
foreign owned companies if his father is
elected no one in my family will have an
office in the White House will sit in
meetings as if they're a cabinet member
well in fact have any business
relationship with anyone that reliably
relates to a foreign corporation or a
foreign country period it was hunter
Biden's work for a Ukrainian energy
company that president Trump and his
allies were pressuring Ukraine to
investigate even though there was no
evidence of wrongdoing CBS News has
learned that the president's personal
lawyer Rudy Giuliani is now being
scrutinized by federal investigators for
his relationship with two men with ties
to Ukraine who were arrested last week
you know other countries are looking at
us
like what the hell is going on in the
United States surgery over the weekend
President Trump admitted Giuliani may be
rough around the edges but had lunched
with him in a show of solidarity even as
Trump AIDS made it clear
Giuliani would no longer be handling
Ukraine related business this week House
committees are expected to hear
testimony from US ambassador to the
European Union Gordon Sunland who in a
text message to another diplomat in
September insisted there was no quid pro
quo involving millions in withheld u.s.
security aid to Ukraine according to the
Washington Post Sandlin will tell
Congress he wrote that text message
after calling the President and has no
knowledge of whether the president was
telling him the truth at that moment
Democrats appeared to be backing off of
plans to interview an anonymous
whistleblower they say they are
concerned about his safety the president
is already tweeting about that this
morning demanding to know the
whistleblowers identity despite laws
that protect that kind of information
Anthony Nancy Cordes Thank You Nancy